foreign
[Music]
hey if I sound windy that's because I've
been running around here we've been
testing making sure that everything
works uh we have look Alex Jones on the
show today and uh I would appreciate
look I know that many have many of you
have different opinions let me just give
you a little bit of a run down here
I was not an Alex Jones fan for a very
long time
uh I made it known I had uh criticized
him here on this show and I still have
criticisms of him
but we're at a point right now and we'll
be talking about this today we'll be
showing you a montage of the end zone
dance from not only the Elites in
Hollywood not only the Elites in media
but the Elites in government
officials uh actually championing this
silencing of of speech and that is
absolutely what it is what regardless of
where you line up
um there's an inflection point right now
in this country and the reason that
we're having Alex Jones on and we've had
him on is because I hate seeing people
being bullied I hate seeing a pylon even
if you think he's said some things that
are reprehensible and we'll get into the
things that he said that he regrets and
he's apologized for Ad nauseam
I just can't believe that we have people
in this country let alone people who are
comedians or people who are supposed to
be Servants of ours
uh Champion the silencing of
someone speaking
and there's a very strong message that
is being sent right now and that's why
this episode is largely going to focus
on this it's going to going to be what
they call a deep dive for the kids
uh on
the systematic uh I guess you would say
expulsion of people for wrong thing
and how deep it runs
and the idea that you can just go and
start your own business
um and most important is you know when
you have someone like Alex Jones who if
you've watched his career
and I do consider him a friend now I
will say this on a personal level he's
been around uh from what I know of him
he's a good man a flawed men he's talked
about it here on air to me it's
refreshing when he's on air uh he was on
air on Ash Wednesday and said you know
maybe I drank a little too much and uh
you know I have it he'll tell you about
his flaws but for a man who speaks
publicly for hours
hours on end and then uh misspeaks or
get something wrong
and then apologizes
and that is punished anyway
and then the government jumps in people
will I guess former press secretary but
current members of the government and
entities who are backed by the
government be it Banks
be it big Tech organizations
deciding to put you in stocks in the
Town Square the message is really loud
and I I hope that you're hearing it if
you make a mistake not only is there a
double standard which we'll talk about
if you have a belief that other people
find to be offensive and of course it's
a sliding scale we know that we've gone
further and further down the trail here
look behind you there's a slippery slope
and you apologize anyway
they only get worse what do I mean they
the left
I mean the left
why is it left or right they've made it
left to right
there's there is no one on the right and
no one here in this studio
who would end zone dance because of a
worthy adversary being silenced and
certainly not if they apologized and
said that they were wrong we've hosted
those people on the show
people like Naomi wolf people like Alex
Jones actually
if you say something
that they in power deemed to be
unacceptable and apologize dozens of
times and correct the record
you can still have your life ruined
anyway
people fought for their lives for a very
long time but you know what that really
means your livelihood
make no mistake when government-backed
entities can take away your livelihood
should it be that you decide to purchase
ammo
off of PayPal
or decide to as a doctor question the
efficacy of a vaccine or even just run a
clip from the Pfizer executive herself
and you get removed
or your host on air
and you speak your opinion wrong as it
may be and then apologize and you can be
punished removed and your livelihood
eviscerated
wars were fought
for less than and I'm not of course
really clearly not advocating war just
before before the CNN folks want to run
a highlight reel I am giving you
hopefully the scope the depth of the
problem that we're dealing with here
your livelihood is something you
shouldn't feel guilty
when it's at risk and it's at risk for a
lot of people
it's something certainly Worth Fighting
For
and it's something that people have
fought for
look at any great look at any huge trait
and I say great I mean the Great War the
Great War right is what they call it
before they had World War one and two
and they said well I guess we have to
separate it called we can't really call
it the Great War we'll call it World War
one and two not saying Wars are great
I'm using the term here look at any Epic
War battle they were fought over what
now not just religion
land
resources
access to water
why
to preserve your livelihood
and we now try and separate that and say
hey well businesses can do whatever they
want well they're not businesses if
they're an arm of the government and you
know what removing your livelihood is
tantamount to trying to end your life
let's be clear about that
okay well you know what I guess I'll go
start my own I guess I'll go start my
own media account oh no can't do that
we're going to find that out of business
I guess I'll uh I I guess I'll have to
take donations can't do that we're going
to remove your ability to take donations
I guess then it's just back to standard
Banking and why aren't you can't do that
you're removed from a bank
I don't care if you agree with Alex
Jones or not
doesn't matter
and by the way this is so clear it's so
obvious that that's a big reason that
the court said you cannot argue that
this is political persecution
do you understand that was
this child was predicated on that he
wasn't even allowed to argue that
because he didn't provide additional
finances I'm not saying mistakes weren't
made across the board but I hope that
all of you understand the gravity of
this situation there are some Silver
Linings here right now in this country
and we try to come to you as happy
Warriors but make no mistake today is a
day where we need all of you
all of you to be Warriors
because they can remove they can remove
the livelihood of not only Alex Jones
but they can remove the bank account of
Kanye West
several other people by the way also on
PayPal and these are organizations that
are backed with Federal
guarantees and a never-ending supply of
your tax dollars you are at a point in
this country where you are paying taxes
to fund the theft of food from the
mouths of your kids all under the guise
of ah First Amendment only protects the
government
stopping you uh from uh saying something
that's all it does it prevents the
government from stopping you okay
by that same token shouldn't JP Morgan
shouldn't JP Chase whatever their
abbreviation is these things are all
these giant conglomerates
if they're backed by our tax dollars
they're guaranteed if they received
hundreds of billions of dollars and if
you adjust for inflation the last few
months hundreds of trazillion dollars
uh in taxpayer dollars
are they allowed to deny you
your fundamental constitutional rights
what point do we separate Private
Business from government and I say this
to someone who doesn't trust big
government
but one of the roles of government
the only legitimate role of government
I would argue the only legitimate role
that falls under the purview of our
government is to protect the citizens
from external threats that means Wars
that means from tyrants abroad and
internal threats and how do we determine
an internal threat well the good news is
we have a handbook it's the Constitution
and that's not hyperbole that's not just
rhetoric
it is meant to be our way of life
and people are wiping their asses with
it so I don't care I want you to try and
separate your opinions from the man
today I want you to try and separate
your opinions from maybe the the views
that have been expressed and understand
that this is something that is
permeating right now this is a very
pernicious this is it's like the
never-ending story The nothing it will
destroy everything it touches and you
have got to put aside this is the thing
that the left does so well I'm sorry I'm
going along on this cold open go with me
here hit the like button if you can
share this show comment because you know
YouTube's going to make sure that you
cannot find this anywhere go and search
Stephen Crowder Alex Jones Ash Wednesday
at least up until a couple days ago the
video that we did with them wouldn't
have popped up maybe they've changed it
now that some eyeballs are on it
laughs
this is uh
it's more important than just taxes and
it's one of the few legitimate roles of
government
and we do need right now government to
actually start doing their job
their only job again that falls under
their purview and protecting you the
citizens from external threats but more
importantly having Representatives
having people who protect you from them
and you know what was supposed to be a
safeguard against that this is what's so
brilliant about the Constitution it was
supposed to be a safeguard against that
if the government should become corrupt
well there's also supposed to be freedom
of the press
why so they can call the government
to the mat they can hold them
accountable
you think that's what's happening now
think that's what's happening now when
they've rescheduled their programming to
give you another January 6th hearing
last time they canceled it by the way
you can go and watch our stream on that
three and a half hours the ins and outs
so we have your right to speak freely
well that's gone then we have the
freedom of the press
they're not interested in that
it comes down to you
come down comes down to what you can do
your voice and who you elect and who you
hold accountable this is the issue this
is the same issue that by the way
determines whether you can Bank
determines whether you can you can
choose to hire who you want to hire that
determines which institutions
in which you can take part and
determines by the way where you can
speak
determines if you're allowed to keep
your kids if you choose to not put them
on puberty blockers you remove the
ability for you to speak
and it starts with someone else you go
well that's not me that's far that's far
more offensive that's that's Way Beyond
the pill that may be
but Alex Jones is Not The Only One
they want to make an example of him
because they want do you feel that they
wouldn't feel that everyone feel that
tension
everyone feel that fear
that's not something that we felt here
in this country
I get it Barack Obama horrible president
liar makes up words we weed up hilarious
because he's such a [ __ ] artist but
the tension of ooh man I might lose my
bank account
I might I might be fine twenty five
hundred dollars if I purchase ammo
legally on PayPal that tension right now
people going what can we say what can we
not say or lose our livelihood
that's a first
that's a first
and that can't stand
and that's why we're doing the show we
are today let's go hey guys
whistleblower again over the past few
weeks late night hosts have all had to
quarantine and do their shows from home
this is a very Noble thing to do in a
time of Public Health crisis such as
loan
let's zoom in on that
more just as I thought it's the same
wall
they thought we wouldn't notice but this
Smoking Gun tipped me off it will
disappear we remember that we're not
goldfish well Trump has the memory of a
goldfish who smokes weed do they really
expect us to believe that with
multi-million dollar budgets and
hundreds of writers that they're just
this unoriginal no they haven't been
quarantined at all they've been forming
a secret cabal aimed to destroy late
night comedy with terrible writing and
apathetic production value and they hold
all their meetings in a rented bedroom
of the Mark Twain House
thanks for watching guys I'm just gonna
plug my GoFundMe here again uh I just
signed the lease on a new apartment
after getting that MCN deal but it
turned out to be a bit of a scam
I lost my whole life savings
explore health
thank you
[Applause]
this fall prepare
for two
Rebels with a cause
[Applause]
the rebels with a cause Comedy Tour
tickets on sale now at
ladderwithcrowder.com tour
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
the hell's the difference
[Laughter]
we've had a lot of good days a lot of
big wins and I hate it when people are
just woe was me everything is dark
that's not true but this is when you see
what's happened in the last 48 hours
alone I'm pissed I really shouldn't be
in this hosting chair because I still uh
you know wake up like a boiled prawn uh
I was 11 pounds down for now I'm six
pounds back up with the fluid so thank
you for all your wishes I appreciate it
by the way today we have Alex we'll also
be going to mug Club please do consider
joining up lottery.com it's 99 annually
69 for students veterans active military
you get the wonderful mug and you get
the extra full
100 extra show and I'm doing the
percentage because it's basically the
show times two it is yes so it's like
you're getting 50 of a show but it's
better to say you get 100 of a show and
then there's another so it's 200 percent
which is impossible I don't know I'm not
a math Asian someone didn't grow up
planting rice that's true I learned that
yesterday corn and Rye yeah I'm American
damn it thank you
I'm gonna give it 110 oh so you're a
liar
you're holding back yeah you were
holding packages saying yeah that's all
I got it's not all you got so we have a
lot to get to today uh originally we
would have been doing the January 6th uh
obviously the streaming of the oh
hearing I'm sorry is there a
thunderstorm they may cancel it yeah
they may move it too no the entire media
canceled it so they could all run it
today we did three and a half hours
remember the attitude there was we said
screw it we're doing it anyway because
we prepared we'll recirculate that go
and watch that go watch that today maybe
we could just stream that again on the
channel today while the hearing's going
on so people can watch it just so we can
make fun of them yeah and if you're not
a member of mug Club sorry we can't take
your chat but please Mud Club send in
your chat your questions that you have
for Alex Jones we'd like to ask some of
your questions because I know there are
a lot on your uh on your mind right now
we'll give you the ins and outs but
always helps to hear from you the little
person now
and you could put uh you could put our
video up against this and see how close
we were
yeah so you probably could make it work
so all right by the way they're doing
the Parkland shooting they reached a
verdict that they're gonna announce
isn't it just guilty and Fry him I mean
I thought this was a pretty closed let
me know when uh when we have the
broadcast uh Vegas
yeah yeah I mean I know the guy's dead
so but you know maybe some facts about
what maybe about Sutherland Springs
fifth deadliest in American history we
look there's a reason that media is
trying to determine the rules and
guidelines here on YouTube and that's
what nothing would make me happy it's a
live show Monday through Thursday 10 a.m
Eastern
uh you can watch here on YouTube I would
love for you to watch it on Rumble I
would love for you to watch it on mug
club and by the way you could see just
so you know the numbers lower on YouTube
because they're much higher on Rumble
and they're much higher on mug Club oh
yeah yeah can you imagine take the
number that you see on YouTube now and
more than double it oh yeah because a
lot of people have migrated if you have
not yet that's totally fine we want to
make sure that you have the free con of
content available I know some people are
in countries where maybe you're not able
to access the apps or maybe Rumble
doesn't necessarily work as well for you
but if you don't eventually join another
platform you do lose your right to [ __ ]
just like if you don't vote you can't
[ __ ] if you don't support the people
who are trying to give you what it is
that you want and we can't create our
own platform but Rumble has and of
course we have mug Club right now where
you get access to the entire Blaze
catalog there's a whole bunch of
programming there uh you lose your right
to [ __ ]
so we do appreciate the support and
we'll be talking about things that would
get us banned on YouTube uh Dave and I
of course are on the rebels with a cause
Tour Nashville November 12th Ryman
Auditorium we added a 9 30 show so
that's also something Rebels is that
what I said we're gonna be wrong
The Gerbils Without a Cause
gerbils
Jules does it take to screw in a light
bulb yes
we're hamburglars well stop this one I
talked myself into a corner
there's no good way to test this joke
and then Baltimore December 3rd because
we couldn't find a venue in DC sorry you
have to go to the [ __ ] that is
Baltimore but hey at least it's not
Haiti uh DC yeah or DC no Baltimore's
worse than DC is it it's DC without any
of the charms well I mean the people
sure and you can go to uh louder with
crowder.com where to buy tickets uh so
we'll be talking about Alex Jones today
we'll be talking about uh the insane
double standard of the fines that Alex
Jones has had to pay uh we'll be talking
about the backing by the government for
all these entities who are going after
Alex Jones and of course we will be
talking about the left has a new dating
app to compete with conservative uh
dating the dating app that has been
released uh thank you so much for
filling in both of you but Cheryl day
thanks you did a great job yesterday
thank you very much I appreciate it I'm
glad I'm back in my chair great you
ready you fired up I'm ready absolutely
we're talking with Alex in about 10
minutes I know I know can we can we see
if they can wait an extra 10 minutes
just because you know I gave him one
hell of an intro
sure and then uh we have uh Dave Landau
he filled in Monday Tuesday thank you
sir how are you good Ahoy I'm fine all
right I've been blackpilled for years
let's do this yes
might as well go out with a bang day I'm
just saying watch me be right well
that's the thing he's been he just said
he's been banged for years yep so we
have uh I guess not so much of a pill as
it is a
an injection why am I doing this
[Laughter]
I'm still a little sick I'm sick
physically but that makes me sick as my
grandfather my French Canadian
grandfather used to say he's six my lab
then I never know what that meant my lad
means sick yeah he was trying to say
you're sick in the head yeah yeah so I
would say that for years as kids when I
saw some someone being crazy I'd go uh
he's six Milad I feel like oh your son's
[ __ ] is this why you were bullied
yes among many reasons I too was black
buildings shooter
now uh and I wasn't doing laundry with
the black pillar either we didn't become
friends over the uh over the Celtics and
the Lakers oh I guess you knew the same
pillar
[Laughter]
all right let's watch and react really
quickly uh you know what let's let's
just do that tomorrow I think they're
watching react we have to move into this
so uh I don't know if you know this but
um there is a uh a dating app obviously
you guys might have known about this
um
in comment below what you think this
Alex Jones thing means for free speech I
mean I'm sure that the chat's just going
to be lighting up in the comments on
YouTube comments shares likes they help
the algorithm if you don't want to join
mug Club that's what you can do is you
can go click and I know some of you like
ah it burns but you know what it's tough
enough it doesn't burn uh Monday I think
Dave talked about there's the new
conservative dating app the right stuff
and if you don't remember here's a
refresher why do you want a date a
conservative
for me at least I know that we're going
to start off with some shared values
while the conservative men I've dated at
least know how to treat me like a woman
in my personal experience conservative
guys have better manners I like that
they understand their role in the
relationship as a man
I just prefer my men to be masculine
and what's the biggest red flag when it
comes to dating a Democrat no Democrats
a Democrat can't be a Democrat a
Democrat that's easy a Democrat no
Democrat nailed the demographics
very diverse find the right match
download the right stuff today there's
gonna be someone I mean they have every
group there someone wheel out in a
wheelchair Republicans
yeah they gave her an Indian girl a
tanning bed where they come back when
you're real black it's Native American
yes I'm sorry native
I think I I think we're both wrong that
wait well
this is a bad day now Italian here's the
thing we actually wanted to get in the
dating game uh because you know the
daily wire can't be the only one to
collect all those all those all those
dollars all those gold coins so we got
into the dating app game but there's a
different approach uh and that's because
look this is just Market this is just
the market I don't care that I'll make
money off of liberals so there's a now
that we've created a left-wing dating
app today we brought in a group of
liberal young women to get their
thoughts on what they look for in a he
him partner
what do you look for in a partner
he's got to be in touch with his
feminine side they have got to be
tolerant and sensitive well he's got to
be a cat person
why do you want to date a liberal man
they're all vaxxed in boost
well I absolutely love minorities well
liberal men all know how to look past my
burden
Love's in the air what is the biggest
red flag when it comes to dating a mega
bro alt right gag
yeah not a Nazi he can't be a Nazi a
Nazi a Nazi a fat Nazi
Jews
find out what slim pickings are still
available at this point in your life
Go download The Leftovers today
available on the App Store and Google
Play
brought to you by George Soros
that's wonderful day by the way I would
have I would have been worried about
that being taken out of context until I
realized that we did transgender
breastfeeding Hitler on the show so
wouldn't be the first swastika armband
he was also on the grinder denier I
believe it's chest feeding yes chest
feeding
now they have tampon dispensers in men's
bathrooms too yeah what do we use it's
just rolled up fast food napkins now uh
Alex Jones will move we have to because
I want to make sure we give him the
floor for those who don't know if you've
been living under a rock the verdict is
in from the second trial the jury
ordered right-wing conspiracy theorist
Alex Jones to pay nearly 1 billion
dollars in damage it for falsely
claiming they were actors who faked the
tragedy parents who lost their young
children and then faced a decade of
Torment far-right Infowars host Alex
Jones to pay nearly one billion dollars
in Damages eight families and a first
responder sued the far-right conspiracy
theorist for the lies Here Comes The End
Zone dollars and damages to the families
of eight victims of the Sandy Hook
massacre which he repeatedly called The
hoax he tormented these families he
accused them of faking their children's
deaths by the grace of God sometimes
bad things happen to Alex Jones
that's a good thing now go get that
money for those parents you disgusting
pink garbage person hey what about the
money for the dentist who almost got
killed because you blamed him for
hunting Lions which by the way is the
main mode of uh of economic of economic
freedom in uh Play What where was it was
it Zambia I can't remember which yeah
Africa's a continent yeah I understand
that
I was narrowing down continent was it
Mozambique yes
southern hemisphere somewhere there were
50-something lion eatings that you yeah
in that municipality and this is the
point that I want to to get to look Alex
Jones screwed up in some areas and he's
been on the show and he's apologized for
them okay we all make mistakes and Alex
Jones has evolved quite a bit uh but he
did not call those parents by name and
torment them as you've heard these
people say he did not do that he did not
call out the parents by name he did not
torment them he did not demand that his
followers go and harass these people so
you can disagree with some of the things
that he said you can disagree with some
of the conspiracies of course and I do
but you can't support this verdict based
on a lie and I will tell you this any
comic or comic host who Champions this
is no friend of mine
Line in the Sand you're a comedian oh
you think socialism
we'll talk we'll talk about uh I'm gonna
talk about Bill Burr here next week and
his support for socialism you can't
separate it name me one socialist
country that's ever existed that allowed
for freedom of speech one ever even the
Nordic models which really aren't the
Norwegian socialist models which by the
way aren't also that socialist so Alex
Jones made mistakes he made some bad
ones he apologized but
there are some examples and we it's not
uh the standard for whether you live in
a free country is not if there's a law
or Vlogs this it's whether the law is
applied equally
and it's not even close while we're
talking about the double standard we can
point you to some lies that have taken
place just in the last month two months
that have actually killed people
with a full-fruited support of the
government so let's go to here here's a
claim for example that was made for a
long time a claim now that could have
been wrong or it could have been a lie
I don't want to get banned from YouTube
because maybe it'll be considered
misinformation if I say I believe it was
a lie why because there are so many
people involved with getting it wrong
that no one even seemed to fact check it
but speed of Science and what have you
yet politicians you had journalists you
even had the Pfizer CEO they made this
claim and it was it borla yeah Albert
Albert borla they claimed that the
vaccine
it's
stopped transmission this is the claim
believe Your Lying Eyes your choice not
to get vaccinated
and to listen to these pundits that are
profiteering of misinformation
intentionally misinforming you
comes at a real societal cost we have in
hand all the vaccines we need to get
every American fully vaccinated
including the booster shot
there's no excuse
no excuse for anyone being unvaccinated
this continues to be opinion but there
are plenty of reasons vaccinated
so we got to make more progress that was
this year July 4th I haven't gotten your
kids vaccinated not before please get
them vaccinated Freedom look out for
their interest here
it's the best way to protect them the
only conclusion one can reasonably come
to from looking what I've told you over
the last that you have soulless eyes
please get vaccinated it will protect
you against the surging
instead of the virus being able to hop
from person to person to person
potentially mutating and becoming more
virulent and drug resistant along the
way or now we know that the vaccines
work well enough that the virus now we
know every vaccinated person
data that you are getting from Israel
and other studies will help us
understand this better but there are a
lot of indications right now that uh are
telling us that there is
a protection against transmission of the
disease okay oh really what data Hans
Gruber voice yes
then of course some of you are saying
well no they just said they just said
that it would reduce hospitalizations no
all references available louder.com you
can go and watch the full context of
those clips they said it stopped
transmission
people got vaccinated and by the way in
Europe people below certain age
thresholds depending on the they don't
do the vaccine because they have said
that there are certain categories of
people certain demographics of people
where the risk doesn't outweigh the
reward not saying because we don't want
to be banned from YouTube Feel That
tension feel that [ __ ] tension that
shouldn't exist when we quote the CDC
when we quote doctors on this God
forsaken platform please For the Love of
All That is Holy go over to rumble and
Mud Club please just please I don't want
to have to tread lightly on this [ __ ] so
they said no it stopped transmission
yeah here's the truth
there's no way they could have known
that how to ask me how I know how do you
know Stephen we talked about this
yesterday but I was still sick and on
flu medication so it didn't fully dawn
on me Janine small Pfizer's president of
international developed markets whatever
the hell that means
reveal they knowingly lied on a massive
scale and the media and the government
carried their water as it related to how
much evidence
any evidence about the vaccine and
Transmissions
plus the Pfizer covet vaccine tested on
stopping the transmission of the virus
before it entered the market
if not please say it clearly if yes are
you willing to share the data with this
committee and I really want a straight
answer yes or no and I'm looking forward
to it thank you very much
um regarding the question around
um did we know about stop and
humanization before it's entered the
market no these
um you know we had to really move
understand what is taking place in the
market if you saw laryngeal you need
your battery oh you need this I don't
need this it's all junk just like
Pfizer's [ __ ] now
um they wanted to keep you out of
restaurants in New York they wanted to
keep you from traveling in countries
around the world with a vaccine passport
they wanted to make sure that you
couldn't go to your job 14-day
quarantines exactly if you didn't have
the vaccine they made you the enemy yeah
it's it's a pandemic of the unvaced yes
and we'll get into but this is just
claim in the truth or if they're going
to go after Alex Jones to the tune of a
billion dollars okay hey are we gonna
look back in time because pfizers had to
pay up many many billions of dollars in
Damages we're gonna look back and say oh
man
maybe you should have done some more
testing can I say that on YouTube
and by the way this brings us to our
other points it's not just Alex Jones
it's you we have the vaccine issue and I
can't even by the way cite if there
happen to be any complications for
anyone I cannot even mention theirs I
cannot even mention the study with
hundreds of thousands of people we're
not allowed to talk about that on
YouTube why because the government has a
meeting with people at YouTube meta and
Twitter and says you're not allowed to
discuss this it's misinformation which
brings us to PayPal they just released a
new policy last week saying that they
would find users 200 uh sorry twenty
five hundred dollars for expressing
misinformation then they said it was an
error now keep in mind this wasn't we'll
just remove you right we'll take your
money out of the bank account that's
linked to us already exactly
not to us I've long since been well from
PayPal I feel you know them they only
apologize for the error after the stock
cratered saying PayPal is not finding
people for misinformation and this
language was never intended to be
inserted into our policy we're sorry for
the confusion this has caused yeah this
wasn't a rumor on Twitter
this wasn't just something that was
being posted on Facebook memes and that
happens both in the left and the right
where it's wrong
this was in their policy so they're
saying there was an error in that it was
inserted into the policy are they held
liable for that
also PayPal wants to dictate what you
can and cannot say what you can and
cannot do
because not only do they begin Banning
the purchasing of firearms in 2020
also ammo how
it's perfectly legal to do and when the
left says we support responsible gun
ownership what would PayPal want to take
part in that and ensure that people are
legally purchasing firearm accessories
and ammunition as opposed to cash only
purchases they always say we want to
support law-abiding gun owners no no no
these these entities they're just
they're not trying to dictate what you
say they won't let me purchase Anno and
by the way they've shut out a lot of
competitors they want to be the only
online form of currency right in the
future and of course they have the
backing of the government in many ways
if you look at the subsidies that
they've had in the tax breaks no no no
we just you can't purchase ammo I'm a
competitive shooter doesn't matter
PayPal says no let's go to California
the state doctors can now be disciplined
as well for spreading misinformation I'm
sure like PayPal is just inserted into
their law as an accident oops here's
from The Wall Street Journal California
Democrats last month enacted legislation
that empowers the State Medical Board to
discipline doctors licensed in the state
Who quote disseminate misinformation or
disinformation that contradicts the
quote contemporary scientific consensus
what yes the Contemporary scientific
consensus that says the vaccine stops
transmission despite the fact that the
Pfizer CEO just said no and the
Contemporary scientific consensus that
says that pain is hanging between your
legs is a figment of your imagination I
didn't think science was up for a vote I
didn't think we had to come to a
consensus science isn't determined by
consensus science is determined by what
is true it's science
potentially be true based on testing
exactly
but you can't overly weigh consensus in
science no no oh these guys uh they say
that uh the sun is uh is actually
orbiting around the Earth
we'll get into that by the way
disappearing it's practicing medicine
remember that was the reason why it was
like oh that guy died yeah well my
doctor didn't even he was like
scrimmaging yes yes
he was skipping pregnancy medicine
exactly
player don't worry about this it's fine
I'm a clutch doctor I'm good uh here's
another example another example Dr Peter
McCullough he was permanent banned from
Twitter he was on our show a long time
ago maybe we should have him back uh and
he's a renowned cardiologist he's been
cited for many many years for quote by
the by the way violating Community rules
um on Twitter
how many doctors were removed for saying
hey the vaccine uh we don't have
evidence of the vaccine maybe stops
transmission effectively not saying it
doesn't for people who said we don't
have evidence that it does that is a
statement that is irrefutable we
absolutely do not have evidence that it
doesn't I know that McCullough has
tweeted about that ad nauseam has talked
about Ad nauseam and by the way has
something to lose
has something to lose doing that
when you're always supporting the big
guys this is the big myth too that the
left says oh Republicans the corporate
overlords you guys are supporting Pfizer
versus a family practitioner
you guys are supporting the White House
versus a guy with an uh with a radio
show
you guys are supporting JP Morgan Chase
Bank of America versus Kanye West and
people who are running for local
districts
all the big companies in the world at a
certain point you just go wait a second
all the worst people on Earth the
bezoses the mark zuckerbergs the
wojitskis
they always want us to vote for the left
shouldn't that raise some Flags
well we're talking about this JP Morgan
Bank Wednesday uh
uh Chase for those of you who don't know
um they sent Kanye West letter of cease
and desist a letter cease and assist I
love how they wrote dear I know I was
like oh good refer to him but dear he
doesn't seem like it would hold up in
court
if they said like Dear Mr West and you
sent it back he's like use my name
yeah my name is not Yi anymore yeah you
can't yeah dear Jesus
how do you know you're a band how do you
know you're a band from uh from from
Chase Bank Yeezy taught me you shall not
pass so dear ye we are sending you this
letter to confirm our recent discussion
that JPMorgan Chase Bank has decided to
end its relationship with Yeezy LLC and
its affiliate entities we ask that you
act promptly uh to transfer your
business to another financial
institution before November 21st 2022.
Again full backing of the government hmm
well it's fine it just put a billion
dollars in a mattress yes exactly it's a
large mattress go start your own bank
we'll get into this go start your own
bank go start your own uh uh Facebook go
start your own YouTube
I'll get that let me just run through
this uh right after the The Alex Jones
verdict now we go from private companies
to um the White House Jen sackey
remember who was objective oh yeah the
[ __ ] now she tweeted out last night the
damage Alex Jones has done to the lives
of these families is
horrific I just imagine that's what she
does probably she's like moving
cupboards and [ __ ]
nearly a billion dollars doesn't solve
their pain but also true that the end of
Infowars would be a public service hmm
sorry you said moving cover I just
pictured when you opened the fridge
she's Zool
hahaha
I am I am the key master are you the
[ __ ] keeper yes sir walk around her
apartment opening everything with her
eyes
like on the phone but dinner is being
made over here because she's a ghoul
[Laughter]
sorry be witch but twinkles that she
just like Twitches her nose and a child
dies yeah
a baby getting burned she just Winks
she's like SIDS no oh geez that's turned
dark that's how she is how the press
conference has ended so importantly who
do I kill in the room there's a lady
breastfeeding it's just a pot of smoke
oh sorry I went oh I gotta go sorry so
here's the thing too all of these moves
are subsidized by the government okay uh
this is the problem they're not just
private companies certainly not the
banks certainly not PayPal certainly not
YouTube Facebook right there's nowhere
to go a few you can fight back like we
said Rumble would love to see that
number today just boom I don't care I'd
love to see that number right now like
Edward Edward Rooney's attendance
computer on YouTube and Rumble
Grace that's what I would love to see
right now so in February 2022 sacky
right now she's saying it's a public
service to end
this broadcast
that's worse than what Stalin said
he just said the press in general was
the enemy of the people jensaki said the
press needs to pay billions of dollars
and it's a public service to end this
man so 20 uh 2022 she pleaded with tech
companies to
actively censor dissenting views our
hope is that all major Tech platforms
and all major news sources for that
matter be responsible and be vigilant to
ensure the American people have access
to accurate information on something as
significant as covid-19 that certainly
includes Spotify so this disclaimer it's
a positive step but we want every
platform to continue doing more to call
out misinformation disinformation while
also uplifting accurate information by
the way the reason she has a Podium is
because there's no legs covering yeah so
splatify is a detergent yes it's very
upset
saki the bit cheek ghost pasaki
Saki
it's there I'm pronouncing it sounds
like something I left in the bowl the
last three days
she does someone you'd pick up in like
that Paraguay it's worse crawl under
your ear so okay backsplash should be
right it should be called sake
[Laughter]
yeah I was saying hey please Spotify
please YouTube please remove these
points of you that we don't like and by
the way if they could get Rogan they
would if they could have nailed us they
tried they tried they tried they've
tried with us the only reason we survive
is because of Mud Club by the way you
notice we don't have 20 minutes of
sponsors in every show and we'll never
do it that'll never happen we're funded
by viewers like you not actually
subsidized by the government or a
foreign caliphate like some of our
competitors so the 2008 financial crisis
by the way uh the banks received over
200 billion dollars in bailouts and of
course that's a low number but JPMorgan
Chase alone received 25 billion dollars
the bank is insured by the government
meaning insured by you here's my
question if the bank basically can only
operate because they can never have a
sustainable business model they can only
operate on your tax dollars they
effectively now are a wing of the
government they're a strong armor of the
government should they be allowed to
deny you your fundamental basic human
rights
foreign
[Music]
businessman hey go start your own bank
uh you can't
there are credit unions
hey go start your own uh YouTube uh you
can't because of section 230
. let me give you to give you an example
okay
and we've I'm incredibly grateful and I
mean that I'm humbled every day by how
many of you tune in I I cannot thank you
enough we compete with the likes of of
everyone out there as far as late news
kind of late night in the morning right
this used to start out as a late night
show you guys said it's too late so we
moved it to the morning it's basically a
late night show okay we compete with all
of them if someone were to say well if
you don't like all these late night
shows go create your own only all the
late night shows had two trillion
dollars from the government and those
late night shows because they were being
funded subsidized or insured by the
government you the taxpayer could also
dictate the terms
the community guidelines on YouTube
Facebook Twitter go create your own
platform you can't
I'm using that as an example you cannot
compete against a business that has a
never-ending supply of federal funding
hope you love Vanguard hope you love
BlackRock because your socialist light
pow-wow Chow brought Elizabeth Warren
also wanted to deem them too big to fail
looking out for you anyone who says any
company is too big to fail is not
looking out for you these two big to
fail companies what that really means is
the government gets to tell them what to
do and then they get to remove you so
you can't Bank you can't speak and hey
if everyone got pushed onto PayPal or
some form of standardized digital
currency you also can't purchase
firearms or ammunition it's not illegal
the government's not making it they're
not infringing on your rights
you just can't do it
because these companies say so well hold
on a second well those companies
wouldn't be in business because half the
country wouldn't support them ah it
doesn't matter if you want to support
them or not your tax dollars do
it absolutely is a First Amendment issue
it absolutely is
this is not an issue of private
businesses
so you can talk about Alex Jones all you
want but you want to talk about Kanye
West
do you want to talk about Dr Peter
McCullough do you want to talk about all
of the shows that have been removed here
online because of a few key companies
who by the way receive favorable
treatment from the government let's just
let's try and take the blinders off
and not just see this with a lens of I
disagree with what so and so or whomever
said because the left is very good at
creating a mop
right they all fall under one umbrella
and they'll make sure that they target
you and because your free thinkers on
the right it's hard the term has been
used as like hurting cats
let's not hurt cats with this one
whether you're libertarian all you care
about is Bitcoin and weed
or you're by God Mitch McConnell's fan
anyone out there
let's let's make sure that we are
unified in this
no one needs to pass a purity test of
agreeing with everything that we agree
with for us to just say hey they have
the right to say it
they have the right to say it they have
the right to engage in Commerce
doesn't mean that they have to be your
local senator
can we all unify under that
can we all you know this is a test today
can we all unify under the fact that
this is egregious what's happening with
Alex Jones can we all do that
I'll tell you because I see a lot I see
a lot of Silver Linings
but if I don't see that today
I'm going to be disappointed in in all
of us we should be able to do that do we
have him I believe we have them all
right uh we now are going to go to I
believe we have them on the line and uh
if you can hear me Alex you know we also
have mug Club extended so please don't
get me removed from YouTube uh it's time
for Alex Jones
[Music]
thank you
Mr Jones okay I see that's I see that
smirk what were you saying was that a
dirty joke
no I said I'm really jealous of that
shirt I'm going to rip it off make my
own copy well
come on now well then now now then I I
want you yeah there's the coolest shirt
that is the coolest shirt I've seen yet
absolutely uh but no but what you're
talking about is absolutely true and I'd
love to give everybody the inside
baseball what really happened with the
case how would the president Center and
where it's going because Alex just one
second Alex because I want to give you
the floor okay uh and it's what's the
best place because I know you have
several sites is it infowars.com so the
best place for people to go yeah so they
want to actually hear what we're saying
and not edited Clips or Twisted
derivatives and they want to hear what
the establishment is so scared of
infowars.com infowars.com forward slash
show and band dot video and if they see
us like a Roman Standard right they want
to capture and pull down and get control
of I am the Democrat deep State
I want to give you this I know I want to
give you the floor but I think it's
really important to set this up and
believe me I'm going to let you run you
know you know me well enough I'm going
to let you run with this but I want to
set up something uh for example when I
had Brian Callan on the show one time
and he was falsely accused of of sexual
assault I spoke with Brian I said look
I'm going to lead this interview with
did you do it and he said no off there I
said Brian you're going to say that on
air and I don't care what your lawyers
tell you if you didn't do it say it and
so I want to leave this right now
because I think this is pivotal and
we've done several multi-hour long shows
but for some reason this gets lost and I
want you to correct me if I have this
wrong
uh so in 2017
as an example because the narrative is
Sandy Hook you tormented the parents you
called them out by name and you
continually harass them from what I
understand and I have some quotes here
in front of me and I want you to tell me
if I'm misquoting you you admitted you
were wrong and you apologize and I think
that's key because I still want to go
after you anyway so 2017 you talked
about an epiphany had on Father's Day
You Said
uh forgive me on Father's Day I want to
reach out to the parents of the slain
children at the horrible tragedy in
Newtown Connecticut and give you my
sincere condolences you said that right
yes okay you also said I'd like I'd also
like to reach out to any of the parents
who lost a child at new uh Newtown to
invite them to contact me to open a
dialogue because I think it's really
essential we do that instead of letting
the mainstream media misrepresent things
and really try and drive this nation
apart you said that right
before they sued me yes before they sued
you and then in 2019 and in deposition
you said and I myself uh have almost
like a form of psychosis in the past
where I basically thought everything was
staged even though I've now learned a
lot of times things aren't staged and
I'm not saying this to embarrass you
Alex I'm saying it because you were
clear and that you had a change of heart
or you believed that you were wrong or
you believed you made a mistake which I
think is admirable and I think the fact
that they want to brow beat you after
that is what is so scary and I think
that people out here would do well if
you're watching to understand that
apologies do nothing with these monsters
you also said so I think as a pundit
someone giving an opinion that you know
my opinions have been wrong but they
were never wrong consciously to hurt
people so do I have this right in saying
multiple times you said you were wrong
and you apologized in one fashion or
another and by the way both before and
after being sued would that be a correct
statement for me to make Alex
I said I believe Sandy Hook happened in
2016 right I said in 2015. and this is
important it's a lot bigger than Alex
Jones it's the anatomy of the left it's
like with George Floyd or something
taking something and then blowing it up
to be the biggest thing on earth it's
like you can take a microscope and zoom
in on a grain of sand and it looks like
the Himalayan mountains but it's not
really so right here's what really
happened yes here's what really happened
I could give you the latest information
where they're going with it everybody
and they've thank you sir
okay Sandy Hook happens it's a huge
political event Obama has it in the
white house that's going on I think
maybe somebody helped the kid kill these
kids
the whole story is bizarre and then
about a year after it
uh all these professors and people that
sound incredible
come out and school safety experts and
say that they thought it was just
completely staged and I'd seen things
like operation Northwoods that talked
about staging attacks on school kids
that didn't exist as a pretextual war
with Cuba and Russia plus said yeah a
lot of stuff's been staged maybe this is
so I did four or five programs from like
2000 and I I guess 13 14
question maybe that it was staged barely
up on the radar it was a huge internet
issue hundreds of millions of views on
YouTube other people's videos my
listeners wanted to know my crew wanted
to cover it they wanted to talk about it
so what they put in evidence against me
was about 24 minutes in Texas about 25
minutes in Connecticut in 10 years this
is the big evil stuff the guy that got
rich off Sandy hooked the guy that wears
Sandy Hook underwear the guy that
praised five times a day to New Haven
Connecticut I mean my mother didn't give
birth to me Sandy hooked it I mean my
whole life is this okay right but it's
not so Hillary and the Democrats start
running this this false news campaign
during 2016 campaign
that I'm Trump's brain they look look at
this flamboyant Wild guy
he's a populist he's got a lot of people
supporting Trump let's make him a
liability let's take the worst stuff he
set out of context and run tens of
millions of TV ads against Trump using
Alex Jones saying he's Trump's brain and
one thing one thing just to make really
clear is just again for the YouTube Gods
you understand how this is Alex
say I'm saying it didn't happen again no
no but they'll say that you what you
were saying because you saw this and
there were other people there were other
professors there were other conspiracy
theorists some of whom turned out to not
be credible and then you didn't have
them on your show anymore you did say
maybe this is staged and just again to
be clear you afterwards said no it was
not staged I was wrong you did correct
it right Alex yes yes and but but it's
important to understand this timeline
yeah so so for over a year and a half
from 2015 into 2016 we've checked the
record I never talked about it one time
and I told the crew this is a tar baby
it's a setup I don't want to ever
discuss it again I think it happened we
started seeing that some of the folks
that were claiming it was staged had
gone even crazier and and we're now
dysregulating and showing that that
indeed they had put out things that were
wrong so I was not the Sandy Hook guy it
didn't put me on the map I barely ever
covered it but Hillary blows it up makes
it a cause celeb for Democrats they use
it to bring back all the gun control and
now attacks on free speech and to attack
Trump
and so then Trump wins they go even
crazier and they start attacking me
saying he's sending people to the kids
houses uh he's sending people to the
parents houses he won't stop saying it
didn't happen and I'm like I said years
ago it happened stop it this is a media
event they're building up obviously to
come after the first amendment so I
issued dozens of Corrections dozens of
apologies you just mentioned one of them
there and then they sue me in 2018 and
then they do all this discovery we give
them all the emails all the text
messages everything there's no evidence
we made money on Sandy Hook there's no
evidence I premeditatedly got it wrong
on purpose and so both Democrat
connected judges
uh one of them supposedly Republican but
she's like George W bush they default me
saying I
hope we lost Alex for a second Alex uh
can you hear me brother this is a
this is clearly the globalist he's told
I'm guilty
the the jury's told I'm guilty I'm not
allowed in in a five-week trial in
Connecticut to defend myself the judge
actually says you can't say you're
innocent you can't say you're bankrupt
you can't say you didn't make money off
of it I say it's all true then they
instruct the jury after five weeks of
crying parents not talking about Adam
lands or killing their children talking
about me well I know that Alex but let
me ask you a couple of important
questions here because I think these are
things that people and I know you have a
I believe you have a highlighter are we
going to roll the Highlight the one that
did you have a you had something you
wanted to show us a clip but um look I
think it's important to note first off
let me ask you questions if you could
just give me yes or no's on this and I
want to give you the floor again sure
did you ever call the parents out by
name on air and say that they were uh
their children like call them out by
name on air
only Robbie Parker okay and afterwards
and and I did not say that that he
staged it or it was fake I said people
think this clip was like 30 million
views on YouTube or more right it was a
viral clip people say this guy looks
fake and so I said yeah it does look
like acting to me but he's you know
under stress whatever so so they've
built this mountain out of a mole hill
right I have one other question two
years and years years and years and
years years yes they gave an FBI agent
who I'd never seen until he sued me
didn't know who he was
he gets up there and cries about me they
gave him 90 million dollars when under
federal and state law you can't sue
somebody you've never said their name
for defamation or slander never said his
name never asked for a retraction until
he sued me didn't even know who he was
until I saw his name on the lawsuit he
gets 90 million well let me ask you
another phone's handing out you get a
car you get a card
well I do have a question that's
important here because people will say
well the reason you weren't allowed to
defend yourself is it was a default
judgment and they say because you didn't
provide the evidence right that was
requested in Discovery give me very
specifics not just all you did provide
and hand over a lot of evidence what did
you hand over because they did have
financials they did have uh certainly in
the Texas trial they did have access to
financials they did have access to
certain traffic metrics when I was
watching the trial they would say well
actually uh they didn't hand over for
example the Alexa reportings as opposed
to the Google analytics reportings what
kind of evidence when you were asked to
hand over just give me some examples of
what you did hand over did you hand over
financial documents is it related to the
company
yes did you hand over documents as it
related to you know like uh different uh
traffic and and revenue streams to some
degree or another
to an extreme degree the most ever given
over in a civil defamation trial many
lawyers estimate Stephen let me be 100
clear so what are they saying you didn't
provide is my point because this is
something a lot of people who do who
unfortunately on the right Alex this is
important I'm just saying this because
people will try and take this out people
on the right will say well then you
should comply during Discovery what
pardon me what in the [ __ ] are they
claiming you didn't provide so that you
were not allowed to defend yourself
all right let me answer that question
and I want to get into people saying oh
this is just for Alex Jones
in Texas
they claimed that
because we did so much discovery
and they would have each person that
they were deposing give them more
discovery
so they'd say ah out of the 200 000
emails you gave us in Texas
um in one of the discovery matches you
gave us there was one extra email that
wasn't in this batch little weird gotcha
games and then in Connecticut
the the the judge kept saying give me
the Google analytics well we hardly ever
even use Google analytics hardly ever
even looked at it yeah so we explained
to the judge ma'am it's a search box for
the back end of Google and a lot of you
have to pay for we've never paid for it
we've barely ever used it but we
searched for Google analytics and found
one writer and and one other person in
the in the group that had looked at
Google analytics and said oh look how
much traffic we're getting a few times
so we gave them what we had in our
system about Google analytics uh take
Alexa same thing they said give us the
election
well Stephen I want you to give me the
Google and then I say and then you say
okay what do you want me to search in
Google right no sir give me the Google
right give me the Alexa we know you've
got it so they filed this unfair Trade
Practices thing that not only did I lie
about Sandy Hook on purpose make money
as they false Acclaim but that I was
making all this money with those lies in
unfair trade practice and then demonized
me selling my own products so that's
really where we are and and for people
out there that say hey
uh this is just for Alex Jones so what
it's the same Republicans four years ago
when I got a platform that said it would
never be president Trump or would never
be them they admit the Democrats admit
they're on PBS NBC ABC MSNBC CNN
celebrating and they've been doing it
for years saying once we set the
precedent
to let government bureaucrats like this
FBI agent sue somebody when no one's
even ever said their name just because
they got heat in public over say
election fraud
now they can sue you and get 90 million
dollars and here is the Secretary of
State
in Texas I've got the article right here
in my stack saying Alex Jones Unleashed
hell this is a republican on US during
the election he caused threats to our
election officials I didn't contest the
2020 Texas election uh I didn't even
cover that project Veritas did I should
have covered it more the point is is
that I'm now The Whipping Boy or the
reason America doesn't trust the
government or the reason the American
people don't trust the media and and now
the Secretary of State of Texas is
talking about we may have to go after
Alex Jones because he caused threats on
Election officials they had no
statements they don't have me saying be
violent I didn't even probably ever even
talk about the Texas election other than
saying I I don't think Beto uh you know
was as close as he said he was to Ted
Cruz so this is the absolute Next Level
garbage and propaganda in fact overhead
shot I want to show people this Texas
Secretary of State Alex Jones Unleashed
hell on our election people
that's the the hill uh here's another
one
Republican Texas election Chief blasts
nuts peddling 2020 conspiracy theory
Zooms in on Alex Jones so just like
they're suing everybody the questions
election fraud or mail-in ballots
they never even sued me because I wasn't
one of the main proponents of
questioning the election like some of
the more prominent people were who
really got out there I did have
questions it's my right to do it but
they're now just circling back like okay
we just got this verdict so now we're
going to say Alex Jones made people
question the elections so now if you
slip on a banana peel or do you have
your car carburetor breaks down or maybe
you get cancer it's Al Shel Jones's
fault so
injected now but yes the point remains
well you know what I mean that's why
it's going to break down it's an old
cars exactly you have you have the OJ
Bronco not the new one that also breaks
down hey did you have a video you wanted
to show or is it us because we have
trial highlights and we have the verdict
being right but I was told that you had
a clip that you wanted to play when you
came on do I have that Stephen I really
appreciate you first off having me on
Having the courage to defend Free Speech
let me actually get this out and I'm
sorry if I'm annoying there's just so
much here and a lot of other points we
haven't gotten to yet that I hope no
you're not annoying at all I just want
to make sure that I was told that you
had a clip or a video let me describe
this club for you let me describe this
clip okay there's dozens of these in
Texas and Connecticut we have a
compilation reel that's about 30 minutes
long of them in front of the juries and
at press conference is saying take Alex
Jones out never let him rebuild his
platform again and once we take him out
we're going to take out all the right
wing disinformation operatives like
Tucker Carlson and the list goes on and
on so so this is the weaponization where
they sue you in Democrat jurisdictions
where they default you claiming that you
didn't give them evidence they tell the
jury you're guilty and then the jury
decides how guilty after you've been
demonized so that's just what happened
in Connecticut so here they are
yesterday just a small clip at the press
conference Chris Manning the former
Federal prosecutor up there who had this
kept controlled jury that was told I was
guilty and then he says we don't want
money from Alex Jones because I'm in
bankruptcy if it's in the clip we can
just watch the clip and let him let him
say how long is it too is it a minute is
it two minutes just so I have an idea
39 seconds 39 seconds all right I want
to run this and then no you're not
annoying at all this is important and
we're going to spend as much time as we
need to I know you're busy but this this
is important stuff and I talked about it
in the cold open today show I appreciate
it when you're ready just just roll I
guess you're rolling it uh from from his
hand we'll roll it from our end then go
ahead and roll it guys all right but we
will be at it as long as it takes and if
you're out there right now and you're
one of Alex Jones's audience members and
you're giving him money I just want you
to know that based on the jury's verdict
today it's not a very good bet uh and to
go back with to what Robbie Parker said
all Alex Jones does is take from you
exploit you lie to you
feed your fears and your anxieties and
your mistrust and the only person that
benefits in that equation is him
well that stops that's stopping today
thanks to the courage of these families
thank you very much thanks everybody all
right so what he just said there is we
don't want money from Alex Jones and I
want to explain to listeners we're going
to appeal this and ask for money to get
overturned then they ask for money we
don't want the 900 million dollars from
Alex Jones damn it uh you can make that
payable to cash
absolutely so so so
if I can I'm shopping with them because
there's so many angles to this Stephen
number one I don't have three million
dollars cash in my company and my
personal stuff I have enough to operate
and you know pay the bills and legal I
got a nice house got decent cars but I
don't worship things so that them trying
to take money away from me means nothing
it'll actually make me work harder to
expose them I'd work for free exposing
them so they're never going to silence
me without killing me or putting me in
prison right and so that which doesn't
you know kill me only makes me stronger
but they specifically say over and over
again they want me taking off the air
they want me bankrupt okay so we're
so we're in chapter five chapter 11 sub
chapter five bankruptcy that isn't
liquidation
it's where we do a plan to the federal
government we say okay you can have the
future profits towards all these
lawsuits in the future in A Five-Year
Plan and there's not much profit around
here so my crew stays hired we stay on
air it becomes a zombie organizations
what they call it because now any profit
but they're not allowed to fire people
or do all that stuff the operation
continues on the list are supported and
then whatever extra is there they get
paid that's in two years at least even
if this is an overturned on appeal so
they announced it's the end of Alex
Jones it's all over it's all more hype
more fraud more disinformation so that's
what they just did here and I have more
clips of them specifically saying we
want to take him out and I'm not trying
to cut you off but some of these
questions are just because it's hard for
me to find the truth the answers on it I
know we talked about we talked about the
cap in Texas right on I believe it's a
is it punitive damages
um yes is there a cap in in Connecticut
or are you unless it is overturned on
appeal are you on the hook for the
hundreds of millions of dollars
the short answer is they lie and say I
owe 50 million dollars in Texas it's
it's about 5.6 there are caps it's in
the state law they can't overturn it
right it's different in Connecticut
the the unfair Trade Practices are cut
my cutmar however they call it uh that
is unlimited and that is up for the
judge to decide so she's going to come
back next week and probably hit me with
a billion more uh so all the other ones
do have caps but because there's 15
plaintiffs they're all capped it I
forget the number like four million
dollars so 10 million dollars is more
money than I can get them of course 50
million dollars is more a billion it's
all a joke at this point it's like
saying we're going to cut you into 20
million pieces well if you cut me in
five pieces I'm gonna die right so we're
gonna we're gonna drop 25 nuclear bombs
on Alex Jones's house and I'm like I
think one nuclear bomb would probably
kill me probably so we're gonna shoot 20
million bullets into you instead of five
bullets so
this is all Overkill it's just been left
having a temper tantrum they want to
scare everybody else and get a bunch of
other lawyers to file lawsuits to come
after all the conservatives and all the
nationalists and all the Patriots and I
really appreciate you letting me get
that out there because it's so
frustrating to me kind of only have my
show that has a big audience but it's
compartmentalized because of censorship
it's very hard to actually get the truth
no it's not just censorship people
understand it's not just censorship it's
cowardice you you you you and I have had
conversations obviously off there where
uh you know I would say I wouldn't say
College of the map but I've said I don't
agree with this I don't like that
remember I told you I remember early on
the show saying I don't like that you
sometimes stir up in fighting with
conservatives remember you saying you
know what I used to do that more and
I've decided the left is a more
important enemy we've had very strong
disagreements I felt compelled to have
you on because some of the biggest
figures in our movement who by the way
agreed with all of some of your quote
unquote conspiracy theories that I
thought were incorrect they didn't have
you on it is censorship and it's
cowardice from people on the right and
by the way I've experienced that too
I've experienced that for jokes that
then people on the right will take out
of context so my issue is not so much
with the left being the left right it's
like being mad that a crocodile bites
you I I'm mad with people on the right
who aren't doing it let me ask you Alex
really Point Blank
I know you talk about Appeals
how scared are you right now
I am way more scared about the direction
the country's going in that they admit
this is a formula for everybody I mean
while the right wing laughs some of them
and says oh it's just Alex Jones they're
on every channel saying we're coming
after everybody now with this model and
they've even got the Republican
Secretary of State
in Texas saying we want to come after
Republicans that question election fraud
give me a break so you have the Rhinos
the neocons the rabbit left Allied
together against the populist uprising
of nationalist Americans who are
peacefully trying to take our country
back so I'm way more concerned about
nuclear war I'm way more concerned about
financial collapse I mean here's a good
point Stephen
quite frankly the way inflation's going
the way it accelerates towards why am I
Republican Zimbabwe
in 10 years there's such inflation a
billion dollars will be like a thousand
dollars yeah I mean at the current rate
we're at here so
no I'm not scared I am uh disgusted
and I really feel proud of myself
because I've told the truth about this
I've said when I was wrong they have
created this whole synthetic identity
for me
the straw man and then they sat there
and had to lie to a jury and suppress
the truth and tell him I was guilty and
rigged this kangaroo court so I myself
can hold my head tall but I am in
general very concerned for my children
for the country in the future because of
the Rabid acceleration into total and
complete corruption I uh if uh and I
know you have some of the things you
want to hit I don't even know if we want
to we can probably show the clips on
YouTube but Gerald here uh I know has a
question for you you can't see him but
uh he's he's championing at the bit
Gerald yeah please yeah so you said
earlier that this is going to be
overturned why do you think that it will
be overturned not that you just have
kind of this faith in that that's going
to happen but what are you guys arguing
if you can reveal that to us on how it's
going to be overturned
well that's an excellent question I have
talked to dozens of very well-known
constitutional lawyers I can tell you
Norm pattis is a very well-known
successful lawyer around the country
he's talked to current and former judges
in Connecticut and in New York federal
and state that say this is the most
insane craziness they've ever seen the
judge said in open court I said this
months ago because she'd done
rules and Lemony and told us what I
couldn't say she said in court can't say
her innocent can't say you barely ever
talked about these people can't say you
didn't make money off of it can't be
political but they could hold up
magazines I put out exposing Obama but
then we couldn't respond back to it she
literally tied our hands
and did this so either America's gone
and completely done or in Texas and in
Connecticut if I have the money for the
appeals that's why they want to bankrupt
us right now right because they are so
scared that if there's any justice left
at the Texas or the Connecticut Supreme
Court or the U.S Supreme Court they've
got to overturn this because the Deep
State the the ambulance Chaser Brigade
are openly saying they're coming after
everyone with this just like when I got
started saying that you think the people
in the appeals court will will see the
gravity of it is that is that what
you're saying why you believe it'll be
overturned
I don't know the fix is in that high but
I know that when okay they've got their
pound of Flesh they've demonized me
they've brought back up Sandy Hook
they've made a bunch of money for their
Charities they got 73 million dollars
from Remington I mean these dead kids
are cash machines for these lawyers okay
and now nobody knows who Adam Lanz is to
kill the kids they only know Alex Jones
and so
I'm sorry what's the question Stephen I
apologize no no I think I think you
answered the question is it well I think
Gerald really wants to know why do you
believe it will be overturned do you
think it's because they wanted to make
an example of you and then when it comes
down to the actual constitutional law it
won't hold water is that why
absolutely I mean I think that well they
have to or the country's over I mean you
have to understand when I say Kangaroo
Court when I say show trial I mean this
has never before been done a defaults
when you just don't even show up we gave
them everything exhaustive and then they
let them use the discovery that they
said we didn't give them to the jury
they could put on evidence we couldn't
challenge the evidence and I couldn't
testify that's why I didn't testify when
it was time for our quote case there's
only a hearing and damages the judge
found me guilty again since when well
the judge knows best they've never done
that before they can't do that you know
if I was caught bank robbing
uh or something and I ran off to another
country then you can have default
judgments to say take my house because
I'm not there there's video me robbing
the bank I've left the country they can
sue they can get the house that's a
default judgment I was there I
participated I did the depositions I had
my crew members go there I spent
millions of dollars on lawyers but
because there was no case there they
were forced to default because they
decided I was the super villain and they
wanted to set this precedence so so yes
all the lawyers agree that if we file a
good appeal with the hundreds of bad
things they did that it must absolutely
be either partially or totally
overturned and if it isn't overturned no
I'm not scared Stephen because I've said
on air the truth I have less than a
million and a half dollars in my bank
account sounds like a lot to the average
working guy and I get it with all my
bills and crew and all this that's
that's on empty my company has less than
a million dollars in it right now and
that's to buy product and pay payroll
and funnel operation so I never did this
to make money they they had all these
fake numbers they had all our finances
they said he made 61 million dollars
last year our growth was 61 million
dollars I paid myself 200
000 last year it's all in the bankruptcy
court they know it they know it's true
was there a year that I paid myself 12
million dollars absolutely the year of
the divorce with my ex-wife six years
ago thank God it was the Trump error for
the first time ever we had all this
extra money right when she divorces me
it goes through the process and the
court made me pay her close to 10
million dollars to quote buy her out of
the company because I've been married to
her for 13 years so the one year God
came through the one year that I because
usually I make about a million two
million dollars a year but honest with
my audience and after all the bills and
stuff and legal crap it's gone of course
okay but I don't do it for money
the one year I made 12 million dollars
God came through magically the money
came in to then buy my ex-wife out of
the company so again they think
trillion dollar judgment I want to say
something here that's important because
I see you and we all struggle with this
right where you're saying oh because I
know that people think that sounds like
a lot of money and it's sad that you
even have to say no you don't do this
just for the money but you absolutely
deserve to earn a living if you have
millions of people who are listening in
the amount of work that you put into it
I understand it this is what I do here
as well conservatives are the only ones
surprisingly the people who support for
Enterprise where we feel like because
our audience is largely working class
you want to say look look don't get mad
at me because I I make this money
because there's a huge difference
between one year making 12 million and a
several hundred million dollar judgment
you know who makes 12 million every
single year uh Colbert Fallon no one
cares and I just hope that people on the
right don't use that as an attack well
you know what oh maybe he'll go cry into
his millions that is not the point and
just for some inside baseball for people
who don't necessarily know want to
corroborate some of what you're saying
yeah you can't prove that you didn't
make money off of Sandy Hook just like I
can't prove that I didn't make money off
of that uh the guy who was fired from
Vox who started the Vox apocalypse why
because this Enterprise makes the only
way that we make profit is people
signing up because they want to hear
what I have to say and sometimes what I
have to say involves a specific person
of course it would be hundreds of
thousands of people if you were to go
over the if you were to look over the
course of our entire program but that
gets pulled in and they say ah you can't
say that you didn't make money off of
insert whatever story you covered here
we've had that happen on the website
just to give you an example just really
quickly we've got someone on the website
Sue because they say well this uh this
actually we don't like this article that
went up and uh we want we want you to
prove that you haven't made money off of
it and it's like well that that article
maybe had a few hundred thousand views
or something like that I don't remember
I'm just giving you an example I don't
remember the specific example and they
were trying to say ah so you make money
you make money off of this your whole
company is making money off no no no no
no they don't let you parse it that's
the lie because you weren't broadcasting
and the broadcast always makes money and
even when you were covering Sandy Hook
that's why they say if you can't prove
the separation of all the streams or any
potential revenue generated while you
were discussing the Sandy Hook issue
then you can't say that you didn't
profit off of Sandy Hook that's the
argument people need to understand it
because we all struggle with it as
business owners
I totally agree and I couldn't say it
better in fact when you said it better
and this is the most important point I'm
going to make here and I got a few
documents [ __ ] show them to they're
really important that tie this all
together
this is a major project for six years
two years before they sued me and then
now the last four was literally hundreds
of Articles a week sometimes thousands
every major news channel from HBO to PBS
to Fox even attacking me uh over Sandy
Hook and building it up into this giant
controversy when I was not the Sandy
Hook man to set the precedent with the
Alex Jones precedent to shut everybody
else down now let's talk about this
being the biggest
defamation judgment in U.S history by an
order of at least 10 magnitude if I can
have an overhead shot here damn I wish
the survivors of Epstein received 965
million exactly good point on Twitter
Eliza think about that real quick why
the church people don't know the names
exactly we still we still don't know we
still don't know
the names of the Johns here's another
good point Purdue Pharma that knew
Oxycontin would addict people and kill
them by the thousands have to pay
634.5 million on the 10 plus billion
they made profit in the Oxycontin case
Alex Jones killed no one ordered to pay
965 million for Sandy Hook lives and I
don't think I don't think anyone is
blowing somebody in an alley because of
their addiction to colloidal silver
absolutely they're not
here's another one the largest fine paid
by a banking executive responsible 2008
financial crisis was 67.5 million jury
says Alex Jones pays 965 million here's
another one yes from a lawyer Viva Frye
Yes except for O.J was found guilty of
the actual deaths of two victims after a
trial it was a Civil Trial whereas Alex
Jones was found guilty of making false
statements about people who were
murdered by someone else without a trial
so O.J pays 33.5 million I pay 900 plus
million and it goes on what's going to
happen
absolutely was found innocent by the
criminal but guilty by the Civil so when
are they going to sue MSNBC for some of
the lies that were done I want one
million dollars my feelings are hurt by
their lies and it just goes on for them
those are some really important points
no I think these are important points uh
and uh you know I think we actually have
some questions from uh do we have some
questions from the audience if you're
okay taking a couple and then we'll go
to mother I want to take them can we
play that one other clip that's about a
minute and a half long of the lawyers
saying shut him down silence him yeah do
you have it do you want to play it from
your end we have it we're gonna go ahead
and roll that clip now here it is thanks
brother I ask that with your verdict
not only
away I ask that you make certain he
can't rebuild the platform
it's what matters
of course
of this misinformation of this peddling
of lies and make sure he can't do it
again
that is punishment that is deterrence
but somewhere out there right now is
another thing
getting interested in school
fixing your lunches
from the work picking up and search it
and the community day when that child
doesn't come home from school and We
Know It In A sadness to your body and
the question is going to be where is
Apple Stills when that happens
he's in the studio
[Music]
get rid of the house
you stop
someone get him that infomercial spray
hair
s
we get all done with all the evidence
we're going to come back
because that's what justices in this
case
and there's many other clubs of the
machine we want him off air we don't
want money for the plaintiffs we want to
silence his future speech so even a
murderer goes and does their jail time
gets out in 20 years but no they're
saying keep him de-platformed bankrupt
him shut him down and don't send him
money because we don't want money to the
plaintiffs because they don't want me to
have money for the appeals because they
know there's a 98 chance this crap gets
overturned Stephen well you know what
else they're doing this is something
else they're doing that people don't uh
fully discuss is they want to make other
people afraid to even work with or for
you
makes it possible for you to hire right
that's what they tried to do they tried
to do that with me to a lesser scale
it's harder to do with a comedian
because they would try and run jokes but
what they're trying to do is also make
it impossible for to you to even recoup
these losses I mean we do have to
remember it's not just Alex Jones you
have many employees there
um and uh so some of them are great some
of them are [ __ ] but a lot of them
are great but this is the thing they
want to make sure we all have them right
I have some here like Yakuza he pisses
me off half the time but I love him uh
yeah they want to make it impossible for
you to do but this is your livelihood
now I want to take uh if if we can I'd
like to and that is bonus all the time
in the world really appreciate you
having me okay so we'll take a couple of
chats here and then uh then uh I'll I'll
have to go to the bathroom I've been
drinking Gatorade I had a horrible
stomach virus be careful out there right
now it's going through Texas like a buzz
saw uh tokenau and let's grab a couple
of questions from the audience here that
we usually only do on Mud Club but it's
a special case yeah I'm a glove viewer
Jerry has a question for you Alex uh
what do you feel was an appropriate
penalty for what you said
uh nothing
it's it's better that
10 guilty men go free than one innocent
man be be prosecuted or persecuted they
got rid of my due process the judge
found me guilty they lied about it all
they hyped up what I said they
exaggerated it I never said people in
their houses it's a lie they're setting
a precedent to steal your rights not
just your rights to listen to what you
want to listen to and make your own
decisions they're literally setting this
up to come after the general public an
FBI agent that I never saw never covered
never said his name till he sued me he
admitted it on the stand was given 90
million dollars because some people on
the internet thought it didn't happen I
didn't create the story that it didn't
happen I covered it right and so a man's
getting 90 million dollars
he won't get it right doesn't exist he's
getting 90 million dollars of this made
up mad money this Monopoly money when I
never said his damn name folks that's
tyranny that's dangerous and also it's
important when you'll get a lot of
people on the left saying oh the right
has a double standard because what about
Nick Sandman and CNN what about Cal
Rittenhouse they said his name the
president of the United States had an
advertisement had an ad that went out
that uh Associated Kyle Rittenhouse
specifically with white supremacy they
said Nick Sandman was mocking somebody
uh this poor Native American Nathan
Phillips as I prefer my Native Americans
to be called Nathan Phillips they said
yeah he was mocking Nathan Phillips and
he was he was stirring up the crowd they
did call out these people by name and
these people had to hire security and
these people had to go into hiding there
is a difference you did not do that and
they did it repeatedly they did it all
day and all night not to mention what
preceded Kyle Rittenhouse was the media
drumming up actual hatred and uh uh and
that's right they never showed any
evidence I sent people to her ass people
or anything of course it was always what
somebody else did right whereas what
happened is Kamala Harris said they're
not going to stop and they should not
stop when answering riots she said they
should not stop the rights the mayor of
Seattle said no this is a Summer of Love
we support what they're doing and then
the media said Kyle Rittenhouse is a
white supremacist who killed innocent
protesters they didn't mention the fact
that it was a a pedophile with a raging
erection and a hospital bag uh hey uh
let's uh token on grab one more question
and then um we'll uh we'll take it to
mug club and when we go to Mud Club I'm
gonna have to go uh I've been drinking
Gatorade all morning go uh relieve
myself Alex but Gerald will take the
chair for like two minutes uh one last
question you're talking about okay my
Club Viewer Taylor Kohler wants to know
if people only knew one true thing about
you Alex among all these lies what would
it be that was going to be my last
question
I mean look I'm a real person I've got a
lot of information sometimes I'm a
little bit obnoxious because I'm trying
to get through it all like here today
and I really appreciate steaming and the
crew being so gracious so I can have a
place to tell the the truth and I
appreciate your courage because you do
get attacked for having me on and just
this is our rights being taken this is a
Hollywood production I'm not saying
Sandy Hook didn't happen I'm saying the
production of what I supposedly did and
how big it became and you know this this
this huge event I'm not the Sandy Hook
guy I'm the guy that wrote the number
one best-selling book in the world the
great reset and the war for the world
that's why the globalists hate me is
because I'm exposing their corporate
worldwide tyranny I'm exposing groups
like PayPal that are back by the way
saying if we don't like what you say
we're going to find you two thousand
five hundred dollars I'm opposing their
authoritarianism I'm a populist I'm a
champion of the people and folks can
actually hear the real Alex Jones at
infowars.com infowars.com forward slash
show or band.video go see the real live
show go see the archives go see the
guests go find out what I'm actually
saying instead of little bitty Twisted
edited excerpts that the corporate media
puts out and understand the globalists
see
Infowars is the flag they want to
capture they're more obsessed with it
than anything else out there right now
because when the global is tuned in they
get scared because I know what I'm
talking about when it comes to the
mechanics of the New World Order
um final question and we're going to go
to a Mud Club and take some more chats
up
what's the next step what are you doing
here next Alex
it's a game plan well that's a really
great question
um my biggest enemies myself I am
absolutely exhausted I'm burnt out I
drink too much uh I I haven't smoked in
14 years under the stress I took up
smoking again
um
going out and watching coming and
hanging out with Joe Rogan there's a lot
of cigarette smoking going on uh yeah I
don't think that's cigarette smoke
no I've done a little bit of the
marijuana smoke too but I smoke a lot of
it but yeah I smoked pot like once a
month or something usually I'm in a
comedy club or go see a movie uh every
time I hang out with Joey we smoke some
pot uh but sometimes I guess twice a
week but I haven't hung out with Joe
that much lately I've been too busy but
there's some days we've gone on it like
twice a week and he's got to get stoned
but a little bit of fun stuff there but
long story short
that's your game plan Alex I didn't ask
your hobbies
anyways well I mean it's a little bit of
a name drop to all the trendy liberals I
think they're trendy and Victor cool and
love the police state and hate Free
Speech I'm the real Rebel Infowars is
the Vanguard so is Stephen Crowder we
are the rebels We Are The Outlaws we are
1776. We Are The Counter Culture not
them and they can't stand that and so
that's what all people know we are The
Counter Culture Stephen Crowder is a
counterculture the listeners and viewers
of these shows that support Independent
Media are the future of not just America
but the world and people can find out
what all the stinks about at
infowars.com so it sounds to me like
what you're saying your next step is and
I'll Alex you know I have a lot of love
for you but sometimes it is tough to get
you to answer the question
you need to get some rest is what you're
saying right your game plan is some rest
recoup and come back
listen I'm more ADHD when I'm totally
exhausted so I've done a lot of
interviews and I was up till one o'clock
in the morning and I apologize
my brain's gone right now so yes I
realized this is what's coming next
I realize they want to take me out of
the game
and I realize that I'm never going to
quit now because they want to silence me
because this is a battle of wills I know
it's the right thing to do but I also
understand that if I take myself out of
the game by being fried or burnt out
they win so I am going to in the next
few months do something I never do I'm
going to take off a week a month
starting at the end of this month
November and December I may take off two
weeks in December I want my listeners to
understand why I've got to do it because
I've got to rest I've got to stop
drinking I've got to stop smoking I
gotta go to church to recharge my
batteries I've got to take you know my
my daughter camping I've gotta you know
go camping and shooting with my son and
my other daughters and so if you're
asking what's happening I'm gonna
recharge my batteries get back to family
get back to God and come back in 2023
harder than ever you know what that
sounds like a plan because uh a lot of
people you know this has been a year and
a half for me since the surgery there's
been some complications that people will
never fully know about and uh yeah you
need to uh you need to treat yourself
with someone you want to take care of
but you know what you just mentioned
something hey
when's Rogan going to have you uh on a
show why aren't you why aren't you doing
his show today you know I don't want to
be mean to Joe
um Joe told me uh was the last time I
was on the show was two years ago and it
was one of the biggest shows you ever
did with uh
who was on the show with me it was a
great comedian really funny yeah Tim
Dillon and Joe's like yeah we have you
in a couple months couple months couple
months and then uh you know it's pretty
obvious what's going on just a little
too much heat for Joe to have me on
which is fine he had courage about the
vaccines he's had courage about
censorship he's been criticizing the
power structure but he's not as hardcore
as Stephen Crowder and I'll just say it
but at least the overall defends free
speech and I just I just don't think Joe
can you know handle it we were out of
dinner about a month ago last time I
hung out with him and uh it's just pet
peeve not to bring it up and I just said
man it really helped me with this
upcoming court case because the whole
media is against me if I could get on
there and explain things and he just
said Alex you got you know there's too
much too much craziness going on let's
just get through this we'll talk about
it later so I'm not really worried about
it obviously I'm the big interview he'd
want he even said listen you're like
nuclear weapons
it's a big deal to have you on but I'm
not worried about it it's really a
question for Joe because I know I'm just
I'm just asking because you know you
talk about how you're hanging out with
them and not only if not him you know he
has a bunch of friends who could have
you on you but he has a whole podcast
Network you know I don't I don't really
have that you know you've been to our
studio it's really just me I'd love to
grow it uh eventually with other people
and be able to you know throw more
support behind folks but right now on
the courage scale on the current scale
Steven Crowders a 10 Al Jones is a 10.
and Joe Rogan's an eight and I'll I'll
take an eight all day over our enemies
that are in a zero of course uh and so
I'm nothing but thankful to Joe for all
the heat he's taken having me on right
and uh and so I totally understand it
and you know what I don't want to give
out any inside baseball here
but I'm just going to leave it at this
I'll tell you all fair if you want but
it's private
um the very same people trying to
silence me
I'm you know what I'm not gonna get into
it on here but there's been some real
harassment of Joe and stuff uh that's
going on oh I know yeah I know that's
happened with him and you know and you
know I'm on that you know I'm on that
list as as well so I know we all deal
with it and uh yeah it's uh it's that's
why I say for people out there who are
watching if you're listening right now
by the way on YouTube please hit the
like button hit the share button leave a
comment below because you won't find it
in the algorithm and I do ask that you
join up at mug Club I do ask that you go
head over if you wanted this is an
information War people should be
flooding you with funding you're one of
the only professional people doing Top
Flight comedy and Analysis I mean I mean
it's better than the production on like
these late shows that have giant budgets
20 times your budget people should flood
you with support and more importantly
word of mouth because I know that's the
real currency we all want is to override
the sensors and to win the Infowars
absolutely everybody should support
Stephen Crowder who's got the 500 pound
testicles well Joe's only got Joe's only
got Joe's only got 400 pounds I admire I
admire Joe's balls okay well Stephen
yours are bigger bigger and even more
juicy well gosh you did say you've been
drinking too much and part of that has
to do with the fact that I have the
under uh under the cabinet microwave
I've learned my lesson all right hey
Alex I made a gay joke so it goes viral
Stephen it's funny yeah and you said you
have to recharge your batteries Alex
Jones is a robotic homosexual uh all
right look uh Jones talks about Stephen
Crowder's juicy balls
oh gosh yeah when do I get my 900
million
um all right look uh if you have to take
a you want to both take we're going to
go to Mud Club here you want to both
take it you probably need a do you need
a bathroom break I've been going for two
hours Well here here's the thing oh
great one I have my own show in 12
minutes so let's take a two minute break
okay you know what we won't take a break
we'll just go we'll do it 30 seconds
we'll go to mug Club it's infowars.com
we'll ask a few more questions
you need a couple minutes but just
remember everything even after this
everything's on air and live so that's
totally fine kids don't do this at
school don't do this at school
infowars.com don't visit it right don't
visit it don't visit and don't do that
unless you want to look really cool okay
YouTube piss off
foreign
[Music]